geschätzte medienvertreter die
pressekonferenz beginnt in kürze
werte medienvertreter ich dass sie recht
herzlich zur heutigen pressekonferenz
die auch online ausgestrahlt wird zum
thema gefährliche fauna afrikas begrüßen
am podium darf ich vorstellen die
verteidigungsministerin frau magister
klaudia tanner
die leiterin des naturhistorischen
museums frau generaldirektorin dr katrin
voland den leiter des instituts für
militärisches gewesen brigadier dr
friedrich teichmann die kuratorin der
herr pathologischen sammlung dr
silke schweiger und den leiter der
dritten zoologischen abteilung magister
christoph höherweg meine damen und
herren vdr voland ich darf um ihre
begrüßung bitten
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin
magister tanner
sehr geehrter herr brinker die adr
teichmann
sehr geehrte pressevertreterinnen und
zuhörer des livestreams liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind sehr
froh heute nach langer zeit wieder eine
analoge pressekonferenz abhalten zu
können und so hohe gäste auch persönlich
bei uns im haus begrüßen zu dürfen wenn
auch unter schwierigen bedingungen
geschuldet ist leider eine bewirtung
nicht möglich wir hoffen dass im herbst
nachholen zu können
ich begrüße sie alle im
naturhistorischen museum mitten im
herzen europas kaiser franz joseph der
erste enkel maria theresias ließ von
1871 bis 1889 dieses gebäude errichten
welches mittlerweile an die 30 millionen
wissenschaftliche sammlungsobjekte
umfasst dabei reichen diese von
mineralien und meteoriten bis über
früheste anzeichen entstehenden lebens
auf der erde bis hin zu unermesslichen
vielfalt an
ganzen insekten vögeln oder säugetieren
und zur nachzeichnung menschlicher
kultur geschichte seit der steinzeit
besonderes interesse heute erfahren die
zoologischen sammlungen der reptilien
und wirbellosen tiere wie zum beispiel
spinnentieren und insekten aus
verschiedenen regionen afrikas sowie die
umfassende expertise der entsprechenden
kuratorinnen und kuratoren soldatinnen
und soldaten des bundesheeres sind im
auftrag der vereinten nationen und der
europäischen union in ländern wie dem
kosovo und bosnien
aber auch im libanon im nahen osten in
afghanistan sowie in westsahara senegals
mali und statt dort erwarten sie nicht
nur ungewohnte lebensbedingungen und
militärische ries sicherheitsrisiken
sondern auch biologische in der form von
skorpionen giftschlangen parasitischen
würmern oder stechmücken dieses risiko
abzuschätzen und soweit möglich zu
vermeiden und im schadensfall das
richtige tun zu können wird seit jahren
durch die erstellung von datenbanken und
informationsmaterial vom
naturhistorischen museum wien
unterstützt
wir freuen uns dass diese zusammenarbeit
weiter bestand hat und frau dr schweiger
und herr magister höherweg uns weitere
einzelheiten dazu mitteilen werden damit
übergebe ich jetzt an frau
bundesministerin maria tann dankeschön
sehr geehrte frau generaldirektorin dr
wohl ein sehr geehrte frau dr schweiger
sehr geehrter herr minister herwig sehr
geehrter herr brigadier teichmann
sehr geehrte damen und herren der medien
die korona pandemie macht uns allen zu
schaffen
das bundesheer ist sehr gefordert
im bereich der gesundheits behördlichen
assistenz aber auch im bereich der
sicherheitspolizeilichen assistenz
einsätze
so viele einsätze wie es wohl nie gab
und da mag man vielleicht das eine oder
andere mal etwas wichtiges übersehen
dass nämlich im durchschnitt rund 900
soldatinnen und soldaten in 16
auslandsmissionen ihren dienst zur
erfüllung der internationalen
sicherheits politischen verpflichtungen
und zum schutz der republik österreich
versehen die frau generaldirektorin herz
angesprochen das sind gebiete
risikoreiche gebiete wie afrika oder
asien
die soldatinnen und soldaten sind im
einsatz in verschiedensten gefahren
ausgesetzt wenn es zum beispiel um
bewaffnete rebellen um sprengsätze
um ihnen oder ähnliches geht er aber
eine dieser gefahren eine dieser
gefahren
das sind auch gefahren so logischer
natur dass man keinesfalls übersehen
darf denn in den unterschiedlichen
klimazonen kommen unterschiedliche tiere
vor die man zu hause in österreich
vielleicht nicht oder noch nicht kennt
das heißt der giftige schlangenbisse
spinnen skorpione stiche oder mücken die
gefährliche krankheiten übertragen
können unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
im einsatz außer gefecht setzen
außer gefecht setzen dann wenn man nicht
entsprechend darauf vorbereitet ist das
heißt es geht um einsatz relevante
gefahren auch und mit welchen maßnahmen
wir unsere soldatinnen und soldaten vor
diesen gefahren auch schützen können
es geht immer um die frage was müssen
wir in der einsatzvorbereitung tun um
unsere soldaten über die entsprechenden
gefahren aufzuklären
ja und dann natürlich auch darum welche
erste hilfe maßnahmen sind vor ort zu
setzen falls doch einmal etwas passiert
und alle diese dinge müssen erforscht
werden denn es geht ja um nicht mehr und
weniger als die gesundheit
die einsatzbereitschaft unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten
wir haben im verteidigungsministerium
eine abteilung die nennt sich
wissenschaft forschung und entwicklung
kurz auch wenn veh genannt
sie beschäftigt sich mit allen möglichen
forschungsfeldern und mit projekten im
internationalen bereich aber auch im
nationalen bereich und bringt doch die
jeweils richtigen forschungs
partnerinnen und partner zusammen
und eines dieser vorhaben ist die
projektreihe gefährliche fahrer hier
arbeitet das institut für militärisches
geo wesen mit dem naturhistorischen
museum zusammen und an dieser stelle für
diese so hoch bringen die wichtige
arbeit ein ganz großes dankeschön an sie
frau generaldirektoren und an die
vertreter der wissenschaft diese
zusammenarbeit besteht schon einige
jahre acht jahre um genau zu sein und es
gibt in dieser reihe bereits sechs
länder spezifische oder technische
projekte zur gefährlichen fauna die alle
über die abteilung unseres hauses auch
abgewickelt werden und einen wert
immerhin von 340.000 475 euro
auch haben bei der projektreihe
gefährliche sauna werden umfassende
informationen von potenziell
gefährlichen tierarten in den relevanten
einsatzgebieten erhoben und dann in
einer datenbank zur verfügung gestellt
dabei werden diese unterschiedlichen
tierarten nach der wirkung auf die
einsatzbereitschaft der soldatinnen und
soldaten im einsatz
berücksichtigt darüber hinaus werden
diese daten mit den grunddaten wie
topografischen karten infrastruktur
bevölkerungsdaten wetter und klimadaten
so kombiniert dass man daraus eben
einsatz relevante aspekte ableiten kann
das ist eine eine datenbank die länder
bezogen ist um die speziellen
risikogebiete für unsere soldaten in den
verschiedensten missionen zu
identifizieren das sind 27 afrikanische
staaten
iran montenegro und französisch guyana
die wurden bis dato in der datenbank
behandelt aber reagiert man der kann das
selbstverständlich sehr viel besser und
auch noch näher beschreiben
die ergebnisse dieser forschungsprojekte
die fließen dann eben in die
einsatzvorbereitung ein vor allem in den
fachbereichen militärisches geo wesen
und militärisches gesundheitswesen das
heißt in der einsatzvorbereitung
bekommen dann unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten zum beispiel schulungen worauf
sie aufpassen müssen schnelle auch
bestimmung hilfen wie sie sich im vor
bestimmten tieren schützen können und
vieles mehr
ich möchte ihnen sehr geehrte damen und
herren jahren auch ein konkretes
beispiel für die missionen mal in denen
hier werden die soldaten und soldatinnen
mit der gefährlichen fauna dieses landes
wie schlangen skorpione und insekten
eben vertraut gemacht es geht immer um
eine bewusstseins schaffung das
vermeiden von risiken und dann die
richtigen maßnahmen im fall einer
verletzung ein anderes beispiel ist die
vorbereitung für die ausbildungsmission
unserer spezialeinheit des jagdkommandos
in französisch-guyana auch hier werden
die teilnehmer über die gefahren die von
tieren aber auch nicht zu vergessen auch
von der pflanzenwelt des
amazonasgebietes ausgehen informieren
und ich glaube man kann wohl nicht
besser sehen welche wichtigkeit welche
bedeutung forschung auch hat und welchen
nutzen sie gibt daher wollen wir hin
künftiger wir haben vorhin von
generaldirektorin auch darüber
gesprochen mit der deutschen bundeswehr
auch zusammenarbeiten es wird derzeit
eine kooperation mit dem kommando
sanitätsdienst der deutschen bundeswehr
vorbereitet um eben die datenbanken in
den verschiedenen bereichen gifte gift
wirkungen verletzungen erste hilfe und
so weiter zu verstärken das heißt
zusammenarbeit auch mit anderen
streitkräften um die datenbank weiter zu
entwickeln und möglichst viele länder
und missionen umfassen auch zu können
der klimawandel der klimawandel trägt
dazu bei dass sich bestimmte tierarten
ja auch in europa ansiedeln können und
verschiedene krankheitsüberträger
mitbringen können und auch da sollten
wir eben durch vorausblickende forschung
gut aufgestellt sein um den gefahren
begegnen zu können
es geht um die gesundheit um die
einsatzbereitschaft unserer soldatinnen
und soldaten im so wichtigen
auslandseinsatz
es geht aber auch um die gesundheit von
allen die hier in österreich leben unter
daher ein abschließendes ganz großes
dankeschön ans ufer generaldirektorin
und dann zieht mein name dankeschön
danke frau verteidigungsministerin ich
darf das wort an privat ihr teichmann
übergeben
sehr geehrte frau bundesminister sehr
geehrte frau generaldirektoren sehr
geehrte wissenschaftler und
interessierte zuhörer
ich habe hier die möglichkeit kurz
weiter zu erläutern warum dieses projekt
nämlich datenbank gefährlich vorne
afrika für das bundesheer so wichtig ist
wie sie gehört haben hat das bundesheer
derzeit ungefähr 900 soldaten im
auslandseinsatz
wir haben durchschnittliche rotation
sechs monate zusätzlich haben wir
militärpolitische entsendungen
sicherheitspolitische entsendungen außen
ausbildungs entsendungen das heißt das
bundesheer in center so pro jahr einige
tausend personen immer wieder in den
auslandseinsatz und das wasser so für
uns besonders wichtig ist dass diese
soldaten
diese angehörigen des bundesheeres auch
wieder gesund zurückkommen und
erfolgreichen einsatz dort durchführen
können und dazu brauchen sie aktuelle
und wichtige informationen über dieses
land über ihren einsatz raum und dafür
ist es meine organisation zuständig das
institut für militärisches gewesen
möchte also kurz die zwei folien die
erste volle die ich ihnen zeigen möchte
sind also alle einsatz räume die das
bundesheer seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
geschickt hat der großteil unserer
einsatz räume ist das jetzt im
afrikanischen und im nahen und mittleren
osten
ich möchte die den prozessablauf und die
logik warum wird diese datenbank
auch einen ganz kurzen einem plakativen
beispiel erläutern
wenn sie sich vorstellen dass sie
geschätzte damen und herren in ein
exotisches oder ein unbekanntes land auf
urlaub gehen oder fahren dann stellen
sie sich die erste frage wo sie wollen
wissen wo ist der flughafen wo ist ihr
hotel wo ist also der busbahnhof und wo
sind die museen und verwaltungsrat so
ähnlich ist das auch auf der
militärischen seite wenn wir den
einsatzraum gehen ist die erste frage wo
ist die pace of operations wo ist mein
einsatz raum wo sind die versorgungs
elemente
das heißt das erste was wir brauchen
sind karten aus dem einsatzraum her
ich habe hier einige beispiele
mitgebracht das ist also die karte
funktioniert
er ist hier ist eine karte von berg
karabach dass wir gerade derzeit
aufgrund der politischen situation
analysieren und damit versuchen wir den
erste frage zu beantworten wo sobald die
frage wo beantwortet ist kommt natürlich
die nächste frage wie schaut es dort in
wirklichkeit aus und das aktuelle
beispiel dass sich also hier bringen
möchte ist also eine militärische landes
beschreibung ja ich hab also hinten auf
dem auf den tischen sind dass er ganze
reihe von militärischen landes
beschreibung aufgelegt hier habe ich
mitgebracht mali ja unter da in diesen
militärischen landes beschreibungen die
über für diese einsatzraum vorbereitet
haben sie sehen also es ist der gesamte
für uns interessante einsatzraum
vorbereitet ob das jetzt primär afrika
ist aber auch der nahe und mittlere
osten gibt es sogenannte militärische
landes beschreibungen
was ist da in diesem militärischen
landes beschreibungen drinnen so ähnlich
wie wie schaut es dort aus zum beispiel
wie schaut es mit dem wetter aus wie es
die straße wie ist das internet
verbindungen
wie sind die ethnien spannung und so
weiter ist natürlich auch ein ganz
wichtiges kapitel vii ist welche
gefährdung habe ich durch natürliche
gefahren
ob das jetzt erdbeben oder flutungen
sagen aber natürlich auch von
gefährlicher fahne und das ist das thema
warum wir dieses projekt aufgesetzt
haben wenn sie diese militärischen
landes beschreibungen anschauen werden
sie sehen dass wir da so ungefähr zehn
seiten
haben die also für unsere
einsatzvorbereitung ganz besonders
wichtig ist es geht dabei um die
vorbereitung für die auslandseinsätze
es geht um die vorkommen wann sowohl
gefährliche tiere dort sind als auch die
vektoren dazu die übertragungs träger
habe es geht auch ganz besonders darum
dass wir eines haben welche gefahren
dort sind und dass wir uns präventiv
dagegen schützen können
zur beantwortung dieser fragen welche
gefährlichen tiere oder fahrer wie in
diesen einsatz weimann ausgesetzt worden
sind oder sind haben wir also versucht
einen potenten partner zu finden
und da nach diesen acht jahren kann ich
sagen wir sind mit dem naturhistorischen
museum so wie es der zu machen
höchst zufrieden es funktioniert
wunderbar wir haben also auch in wien
einen potenten partner gefunden der
gemeinsam mit uns diese datenbank für
diese räume hier befüllt das heißt
zusammenfassend es ist ganz wichtig für
die einsatzvorbereitung wir schreiben
das in unserer militärischen landes
beschreibungen in der
einsatzvorbereitung hinein und dank
dieser partnerschaft sind wir auch in
der lage das kapitel gefährliche flora
und die gefährlichen tiere auch
dementsprechend sicher aufzubereiten
damit übergebe ich bitte an die
durchführenden
ich darf das wort an das team des
naturhistorischen museums geben
anwesende voran frau bundesministerin
frage eine reaktoren afrika danke für
die einleitenden worte es wurde schon
sehr viel gesagt dass wir gleich weiter
auf diese folie
es sind eben bei der gefährlichen fan
afrikas aber auch zu allererst möchte
mich wirklich bedanken für die gute
zusammenarbeit und kooperation auch
stellvertretend für alle
projektmitarbeiter denen ich auch gleich
in unser beider namen danken muss ohne
die würde es nicht gehen wie schon
gesagt es ist ja aufwendige recherche
notwendig wir sind natürlich
prädestiniert durch unsere
wissenschaftlichen sammlungen durch
unsere auch sammlungs bibliotheken auch
die theologische hauptbibliothek ist
wirklich eine quelle sage mal viele
informationen und zusätzlich kommen
natürlich internetrecherchen kontakte zu
anderen museen zu anderen
wissenschaftern all das ist eine tolle
arbeit auch für uns sehr spannend weil
man wirklich täglich etwas neues dazu
lernen darf dieser zeit aufwändig und
daher sind wir für diese kooperation und
die zusätzlichen ressourcen da sehr
dankbar
wie gesagt es geht darum die ganzen
daten dann eben auch ordentlich
verfügbar zu haben nicht dass der endlos
lange liste nirgendwo auf liegen mit
denen sich keiner beschäftigen kann und
daher eben weil er das auch über das
militärische gewesen funktioniert okay
besser so wollen wir das ganze eben auch
dann visualisieren wirklich für die
geografischen einsatz räume ja datenbank
es wurde schon angesprochen das
wichtigste ist natürlich die
einsatzvorbereitung was erwartet einen
vorort wir als wissenschaftler freuen
uns natürlich auch über die möglichkeit
wirklich der der forschung der
angewandten forschung wie schon gesagt
wurde es gibt kein wissenschaftler nicht
schöneres vivendi arbeit auch wirklich
einen angewandten nutzen hat im besten
fall dann vielleicht sogar ein leben
retten kann
also was will man mehr ganz wichtig
daher dann natürlich auch die
fortbildung für die einzelnen
bedarfsträger in das jagt kommando wurde
auch schon genannt das macht wirklich
einen sinn dass man die leute auch
entsprechend vorbereite
der mehrwert der öffentlichkeitsarbeit
ist natürlich auch ganz klar auch für
uns museums menschen die wir auch auf
unser publikum angewiesen sind und immer
auch unserem publikum zeigen wollen was
wir zu tun im haus nicht nur die objekte
selbst aber eben auch unserer
forschungsprojekte und so weiter all das
gehört dazu und ist immer für uns
wissenschaftler sehr schön und wichtig
auch der punkt kooperation
interdisziplinarität ist angesprochen
wird fast sagen das ist nicht nur ein
mehrwert sondern dass eigentlich sogar
eine grundvoraussetzung für das ganze so
ein projekt kann wirklich nur entstehen
wenn man auch zusammen arbeitet und ich
darf in dem zusammenhang einfach weil es
auch aus meiner historisch gewachsen ist
die österreichische gesellschaft für
tropenmedizin parasitologie und
migrations medizin erwähnen weil bei den
jahrestagungen parasitologie shen
fachgesprächen genau dort wurde ebenso
die basis gelegt für diese
interdisziplinarität der humanmediziner
eben grob mediziner reisemedizin auch
viele impfärzte diese jetzt aus den
medien kennen aber auch veterinär bares
ideologen veterinärmediziner und auch
wir biologen die fallen parasitologe
tätig sind oder waren
da wirklich auch zusammengreifen schon
informationen austauschen können
und genau dieses über den tellerrand
hinaus schauen da miteinander auch zu
kooperieren interdisziplinär zu arbeiten
das ist das entscheidende
auch speziell für diese datenbank weil
er soll ja kein statisches produkt sein
sondern das soll weiterleben weiter
entwickelt werden wie auch schon
angesprochen
wir selber sind eigentlich auch nur
biologen können jetzt die medizinische
relevanz nicht überprüfen sondern nur
die daten liefern und das ganze muss
dann auch noch weiter bearbeitet werden
ja die einsätze sind ja schon teilweise
genannt werden viele friedensmissionen
da ist jetzt exemplarisch glaube ich
muss an big und mali genannten
trinkwasseraufbereitung war glaube ich
immer wieder auch ein thema aber
natürlich auch die medizinische
versorgung hier auch noch einmal
aufgelistet jährlich der aktuelle stand
der auslandseinsätze die zahlen können
sich immer wieder ändern aber die frau
bundesministerin hat das ja auch schon
erwähnt kommen wir da für den auch uns
sagen wir entscheidenden bereich sie
sehen schon die anforderungen in den
einsatzgebieten und der partie hat das
auch schon gut genannt wichtig ist immer
wo mobile ich finde ich mich was
erwartet nicht
hat und natürlich immer als
normalsterblicher reisender erwartet man
ihm das hotel und den transfer und
sonstiges bzw auch der rucksack tourist
der sich wirklich vielleicht auch durch
land durchs land schlagen will kommt
schon etwas mehr mit der natur und auch
den natürlichen gegebenheiten in dem
zusammenhang aber hier sieht man doch da
es wirklich der einsatz gefragt wirklich
gerät und auch die mannschaft sind
natürlich gefordert wurde auch schon
angesprochen naturkatastrophen klima
wetter all das muss berücksichtigt
werden
und wenn man dann sagen wir mitten im
nirgendwo auch sein muss und sein kann
abgesehen von den militärischen gefahren
haben wir dann natürlich auch wirklich
den direkten kontakt zur natur und ist
doch eventuell diversen gefahren
ausgesetzt und damit komme ich der auto
zu ein paar exemplare die da im relevant
sein können
ich war vielleicht ganz rechts an wie
gesagt dann gifttiere denkt man
vielleicht in erster linie eben da vor
allem giftschlangen da man kann wie die
arabische wie hat die bahntrasse lotter
geben dann wenn die zubeißt
da ganz nette für verletzungen
verursachen kann oder eben eigentlich
nicht nett die giftwirkung kann eben
auch schnell von statten gehen teilweise
gibt es auch eine gotische gifte und so
weiter wird von giftigen ja man denkt
auch an skorpione wurden auch schon
erwähnt ich habe da auch exemplare
mitgebracht das ist sowas auch sage mal
der normale tourist vielleicht noch
berücksichtigt aber dass man zum
beispiel auch von einem flusspferd
angefallen werden kann
daran denkt man vielleicht nicht es sind
liebe nette große plumpe tiere die ihr
langsam sind neben nicht die können dann
durchaus sehr rasch werden gerade mütter
wenn die ihre jungen sagen wir
beschützen wollen da kann dann auf am
abend bei flussufern wenn man dort
vielleicht kämpft in verbindung kommen
also auch da wieder wichtig wo bin ich
wie stelle ich meine zelte auf dann
etwas jahr wo man vielleicht auch nicht
so dran denkt links weiter in der mitte
oben ein zähler
in dem fall sind das leishmanien im
intrazelluläre blut
kosten die durch mücken übertragen
werden sieht man gleich daneben und ich
habe da auch präparat mitgebracht das
ist dann wirklich nur mikroskopisch
klein
also das sind einfach gefahren die man
ebenso nicht sieht aber die man
vielleicht doch auch berücksichtigen
sollte denn diese schmalen können man
sieht dann unten am bild solche
erscheinungen hautkrankheiten bewirken
die da gibt es im fall daniel eschmann
user aber es gibt dann auch noch eine
viszerale oder eine moderne die auf die
schleimhäute geht also generell sand
mücken sind da im direktorin für diese
parasiten und ganz links haben wir noch
dieses bild baudenkmal schöner käfer
blau gefärbter kurz flügel kefer was ist
an dem gefährlich ja wenn man den
zerdrückt dann kann man auch gar nicht
so nette hautausschläge bekommen
und all das damit sekundärinfektionen zb
gebaut kann wirklich dazu führen wir
auch schon erwähnt worden ist da sind
dann ein resultat außer gefecht gesetzt
wird und das gilt es natürlich zu
vermeiden
und ja bei all diesen dingen kann man
natürlich dann schauen je mehr man zudem
einzelnen tier weiß verhalten kann man
dann auch berücksichtigen wie sehr muss
ich mich verhalten
zecken sind da jetzt gar nicht dem bild
aber da habe ich in einem modell
mitgebracht das ist der gemeine holzbock
sodass rizinus auch hier im glas noch
das ist was sie die die heimische zecke
wenn man so will
und wir haben natürlich auch gelernt
gegen fsme gegen das virus könne und ihn
verlassen
borreliose nicht dann müssen wir schauen
aufpassen und der kommt aber auch
weltweit vor
und es gibt noch einmal gefährlich
rezepten punkt setzen die auch aktiver
auf den wirt zu gehen die dann ganz
andere viren bakterien teilweise auf
produktion übertragen können und wir
sagen ja zum beispiel krim kongo
hämorrhagisches fieber kann man auch
schon in der türkei zum beispiel
bekommen wenn dort die zecken auftauchen
sind natürlich auch in afrika vorhanden
da geht es nicht wirklich darum einfach
daran denken das ist ein satz den ich
auch im bei all diesen biologischen
tagungen gespräche gehört habe wichtig
ist einfach dass man daran denkt dass es
so etwas geben kann
auch dann kamen mit exposition
prophylaxe mittel vorbeugend weiter tun
ja und damit komme ich schon zur
datenbank und da darf ich an kollegin
schweiger übergeben
herzlichen dank wir haben heute schon
sehr viel gehört von der datenbank
wir haben begonnen wie das projekt
gestartet hat vor 2012 mit einer sehr
einfachen datenbank einer access
datenbanken haben aber gewusst das wird
nicht die zukunft sein denn es sollte
auch eine serverbasierte datenbank geben
wo dann alle wirklich zugreifen können
und die im aktualisiert werden kann und
wir haben uns dann entschlossen in
kooperation mit dem österreichischen
bundesheer eine open access datenbank zu
nutzer sein cookies das ist ein
geografisches informationssystem und wir
haben es die ganzen daten in dieses
cookies system transferiert das heißt
alle daten sind auch mit geografischen
daten vernetzt und man kann sie abrufen
und man kann auch karten erstellen und
das war uns ganz besonders wichtig was
ist jetzt dringend in der datenbank
wir haben nämlich ursprünglich
angefangen ja was muss man wissen aber
dass forscher hat man ganz andere
bedürfnisse hat es jemand dann drauf
gekommen als eigentlich dann die
soldatinnen und soldaten im einsatz
haben denn sie haben mit ausdrücken wie
wir verwendet haben oft gar nichts
anfangen können oder mussten hatten ganz
andere bedürfnisse gibt zum beispiel
auch was kann man essen was kann man
nicht essen was ist gefährlich also wir
sind da auf sachen zurzeit sind auf uns
zugekommen weil man es gedacht haben
okay wir müssen die datenbank dann
wirklich noch mal aufgrund grund auf
überdenken den forschungs aspekt und
auch den anwendungs aspekt in der
datenbank drinnen sind jetzt die
potenziell gefährlichen tierarten
natürlich die beschreibung also es ist
wichtig auch dass man die ganz genau
beschreibt dass die leute das auch
erkennen können und es gibt zu jeder art
bilder und manchmal schauen jungtiere
ganz anders aus als erwachsene tiere das
heißt wir haben da wirklich sehr viel
verschiedene bilder abgegeben und wir
haben natürlich auch die lebensräume wo
kommen die taten vor das sieht man auch
schon die potentaten verbreitet wo leben
sie wie leben sie sind sie nachtaktiv
sind sie tag aktiv das sind natürlich
alles wichtige informationen für
soldaten die dann draußen im gelände
unterwegs sind
welche gefährdung geht von ihnen aus das
ist nämlich auch nicht immer klar ist es
eine bissverletzung ist es eine
vergiftung ist es eben eine übertragung
durch vektoren dass deine krankheit
ausgelöst wird und was kann man tun um
diese gefahren zu vermeiden und
natürlich auch wichtig was sind die
erste-hilfe-maßnahmen die zwei letzten
punkte werden von uns nicht gefühlte
während von medizinischem fachpersonal
gefühlt weil das ist einfach nicht unser
metier sag ich einmal beraten hat
derzeit den datenbank drinnen sie sehen
sie oben in roth wir haben 564 arten in
der datenbank also das ist schon
eigentlich sehr viel für den
afrikanischen bereich ich gehe noch
einmal kurz zurück ich habe das
vergessen zu sagen dass sie das einfach
sehen die länder die hier ist farbig
dargestellt sind sind die länder die man
bisher bearbeitet haben die grünen
länder sind schon abgeschlossen die
roten sind derzeit in arbeit mit dem
laufenden projekt nur dass man eine
übersicht hat ja also wirklich sehr
viele tierarten in der datenbank drinnen
angeführt natürlich von meiner gruppe
von den reptilien was eigentlich klar
ist was eigentlich sehr viele
giftschlangen gibt im afrikanischen raum
natürlich auch die spinnentiere aber sie
sehen schon es kommen auch parasitische
birma vor es kommen wassertiere vor wenn
man hat durchaus einmal anlandungen auch
im wasser oder muss auch irgendwelche
wasser bereiche durchqueren
solche tiere gar nicht so wenige und
natürlich die einzeller vor allem als
überträger von krankheiten
wir haben dann wird es schon erwähnt
waren eine kooperation eigentlich ist
ins auge gefasst dann auch mit der
deutschen bundeswehr und dazu hat
2009/10 schon einen workshop hier bei
uns im museum gegeben
man sieht ja auch die kollegen von der
bundeswehr in der uniform und auf den
brigadier teichmann wir uns da begrüßt
und es war eigentlich ein sehr schöner
workshop weil wir uns mal überlegt haben
was kann man jetzt mit seinen datenbank
inhalten was kann man eigentlich damit
machen sind wir schon so weit dass wir
ein satz relevante karten zum beispiel
stellen können schnell also nicht dass
jetzt vier wochen vorlaufzeit sondern
das heißt nächste woche könnt ihr karten
liefern die inhalte haben die wir eben
benötigen
und dazu haben wir diesen workshop
8 und in einem workshop sind dann zwei
arbeitsgruppen entstanden zum einen sind
immer die skorpione in mali bearbeitet
worden und zum anderen auch die
schlangen des senegal und ich zeige
ihnen einmal was wir da gemacht haben
und zwar haben sie mal her gegangen
haben uns verbreitung skaten angeschaut
sieht man links oben im bild die derzeit
publiziert sind haben genau fünf punkte
von unseren eigenen arbeiten von
publikationen aus online datenbanken
auch noch rausgenommen haben das ganze
verschnitten mit den lebensräumen wo die
potenziellen giftschlangen also die dort
vorkommen leben verschnitten und das
ganze hammer dann in einer karte
dargestellt und hatten somit ein
erweitertes verbreitungsgebiet für jede
schlangen art ein sehr genaues
eigentlich und dann haben wir alle
giftschlangen arten des senegal
übereinander gelegt und haben eine so
genannte hot spot map erstellt und das
sieht man schon die dunklen bereiche da
kann man sehr viele giftschlangen arten
vor so 16 bis 18 arten und wenn man zum
beispiel irgendwo im einsatz unterwegs
ist dann kriegt man schon einmal ein
bild wo muss man eigentlich aufpassen wo
sollte man sein kemper richten wo besser
nicht und wir haben zum beispiel dann
auch mal versucht krankenhäuser oder
irgendwie medizinische
hilfseinrichtungen auch noch in der
karte zu verankern und das wäre es so
eine karte die eigentlich für den
einsatz sehr schnell erstellt werden
kann
wir haben das ganze dann auch noch mit
giften gemacht mit einzelnen arten dass
man kann da wirklich sehr viel schon aus
der datenbank rausziehen
wichtig war uns auch dass die soldaten
einen eine bestimmung hilfe vor ort
haben denn nicht immer ist man im
internet oder vor allem das jagt
kommando ist unterwegs in
einsatzgebieten wo sie eigentlich kaum
zugang zu irgendwelchen internet
ressourcen haben und daher mag sagt er
machen bestimmung fulda fürs gelände und
das sind im 2 entstanden ist die
herrschaften von der presse haben diese
folie bekommen also einen von westafrika
und einem von ostafrika und das ist eine
sehr schnelle bestimmung hilfe im feld
und sind auch verwechslung sutton
drinnen also auch um giftige arten damit
man das auf den ersten blick eigentlich
gleich sehen kann
es sind präventionsmaßnahmen drinnen und
auch für die mediziner
erste-hilfe-maßnahmen
und das funktioniert mit einem ganz
simplen system also wir begonnen haben
mit dem folder muss ich sagen haben uns
gesagt so schwer kann das nicht sein
wird schon bilder rein und fertig und
dass sie mal drauf gekommen
die leute wissen nicht welche gift hat
die schlange ewig gefährlich ist sie was
ist die verwechslung sad welche
ausdrücke verwendet in dem folder damit
dass auch das soldat im einsatz
eigentlich auch gut versteht also keine
theologischen fachbegriffe verwenden
also dass immer dann schon an unsere
grenzen gestoßen wir haben eigentlich
recht lang daran gearbeitet aber ich
habe schon gehört er funktioniert sehr
gut und sie können das auch ganz gut
draußen verwenden
wir haben sogar unten sie sehen eine
leiste gemacht damit man das ziel auch
abmessen kannst was man dem so nahe
kommt und sie sehen hier einfach aber
kitsch langen angeführt und es ist so
ein ampelsystem der folder rot heißt
immer sehr gefährlich dann gibt es noch
orange und grün und es ist eigentlich
ganz leicht sich dadurch zu manövrieren
es werden immer die größten angegeben
und auch die gefährlichkeit und auch für
die mediziner das gift damit man
eigentlich ganz schnell reagieren kann
ja wir machen auch zusätzliche
schulungen vor ort man sieht dass hier
so das ist eine schule und beim
jagdkommandos für die klimazonen
ausbildung französisch guyana und wir
haben zuerst immer einen einleitenden
teil wo wir einfach theorien also
theorie machen und am nachmittag gibt es
dann eine praxis und die praxis machen
wir mit lebendigen schlangen und auch
mit skorpionen und spinnen und da wird
einfach gelernt wie kriege ich ja
schlange aus dem camp raus wie endlich
eine schlager wie reagiert eine schlange
wo die schau ein skorpion aus wie kann
ich das mit einer pinzette machen das
denn eigentlich ganz oder mit einem
messer das ich dann ganz leicht
eigentlich weg krieg aus meinem
schlafsack solche sachen werden da
eigentlich dann trainiert und ich muss
sagen das macht den kollegen vom
jagdkommandos spaß und uns eigentlich
auch und das ist immer sehr spannend
ja wir haben das projekt auch
präsentiert im jahr 2017 beim
forschungsmarkt ab der in der
militärakademie in wiener neustadt und
haben da auch ein zelt aufgebaut und
einmal eine situation vor ort simuliert
und man muss sagen haben uns sehr
gefreut wir haben da den ersten preises
wenn der preise vergeben wir haben
den ersten preis bekommen für unser
projekt ich glaube das war dem auch
geschuldet dass wir eine lebendige
schlange mit hatten unseren königspython
hier eben auch eine kleine afrikanische
gütern art und das projekt ist dort
eigentlich wirklich sehr gut angenommen
worden
wir haben schon gesagt
öffentlichkeitsarbeit ist uns auch
extrem wichtig ich könnte jetzt glaube
ich eine stunde nur über
öffentlichkeitsarbeit reden was wir
bisher in dem projekt gemacht haben aber
der zeit geschuldet stelle ich nur zwei
sachen vor
man sieht hier auch mitarbeiter des ing
den oberst gerhard glaser der hier bei
der langen nacht der museen uns
unterstützt hat und da eine ganze nacht
der bevölkerung eigentlich informiert
hat über unser projekt und wir waren
auch wie es noch möglich war 2009 10 bei
der leistungsschau am heldenplatz
vertreten mit am stand und haben den
ganzen tag fragen der bevölkerung
beantwortet ja und wir freuen uns auf
ihre fragen sagen danke für die
aufmerksamkeit und freuen uns natürlich
auch über diese tolle kooperation und
dass das so gut funktioniert und freuen
uns auf eine weitere zusammenarbeit
herzlichen dank wir bedanken uns für die
sehr informative beiträge für
medienvertreter hier vor ort aber auch
online akkreditierte bestehen und die
möglichkeit fragen an das podium zu
stellen
ich darf sie suchen das sie bei der
frage ihren namen und das medium
präsentieren und davon ihre fragen
bitten
bitteschön
dieser formel 1 weil sie so viel
aufmerksamkeit auf die datenbank
gerichtet haben können normale menschen
nicht bundesheer angehörige auch
einsicht nehmen in diese datenbank die
antwort technisch ja ob wir das schon
freigegeben haben zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nein ja wir sind derzeit in ich würde
sagen in einem status coupe concept
demonstrator sache wir wollen den
nächsten schritt den wir jetzt
angegangen haben oder sind ist dass wir
im sinne eines optimierungsprozesses
eines lessons learned prozesses dass in
der einsatzvorbereitung jetzt durch
testen damit wir sodann nicht mit der
mitte mit etwas hinausgehen was es dann
schon mehrfach durch getestet worden ist
das heißt wir machen die interne
testungen wie wir mit dieser datenbank
am besten umgehen können und diese
dieser status läuft jetzt gerade
es gibt einige ideen wie das weiter
entwickelt werden könnte erste variante
die also er schon mehrfach angesprochen
man ist dass man das nicht auf
österreich beschränkt sondern
internationalisiert das würde natürlich
im sinn von einer synergie europäischen
idee und so weiter würde es natürlich
sinn machen weil in vielen dieser
einsatz räumen die ich gezeigt habe ja
nicht nur österreichische daten sondern
zb auch deutscher französischer oder
italienischer soldaten unterwegs sind
also eine entwicklungs option die wir
haben ist dass man das
internationalisieren
die zweite entwicklungs option die wir
auch machen ist wir wollen mal sehen was
wir aus dieser datenbank bestmöglich dem
kunden liefern will der eine
automatische karte sprich eine eine
karte die also dann in eine landes
beschreibungen der einsatzvorbereitung
hinein kommt oder ist das eine art so
wie wir alle keine einer zeckenkarte die
dann zum beispiel im kommando hängt ja
oder wollen wir zb web services anbieten
jawohl sodann die soldaten zum beispiel
über gesicherte verbindungen sich diesen
lehrer herunterladen können
und die dritte option die wir auch
denken in der weiterentwicklung ist es
wäre eigentlich super wenn wir das nicht
eine stationäre datenbank hätten sondern
wenn wir die personen die im einsatzraum
sind die möglichkeit geben dort auch
feedback zu geben dass die user zb
sorgen
ich habe zwar in der datenbank diese
schlangen hier nicht vorgekommen
eingezeichnet ob ich habe eine gefunden
ja und damit hätten wir einen rücklauf
zyklus etabliert der könnt ihr natürlich
auch zu einer qualitätssicherung weiter
entwickelt werden
und je mehr in so einem
qualitätssicherungs einem rückruf zyklus
drinnen seien desto besser wird die
datenbank dann werden das wäre also aus
unserer sicht eine eine selbst
verbesserungsprozess
es gibt also einige weiter entwicklungen
die wir derzeit arbeiten die horizontale
ja leider dankeschön gibt es sonst noch
eine frage
grüß gott wir haben eine online frage
und 20 frage geht wie viele soldaten
werden im einsatz durch die fauna
verletzt
ich darf die frage an das team
weitergeben
herr brigadier bitte zum zum derzeitigen
punkt haben wir keine konkreten zahlen
die ich jetzt weitergehen kann oder in
die öffentlichkeit bringen kann
uns ist bewusst dass das eine gefallen
mit der wir umgehen müssen und dass wir
also dieses thema angehen müssen und wir
werden unser bestes dass im rahmen der
einsatzvorbereitung aber auch im rahmen
der prävention vor ort bestmöglich
durchzubringen
aber konkrete zahlen haben wir derzeit
keine dankeschön
wir haben noch eine weitere frage bitte
schön christoph matzl kronen zeitung
grüß gott ich darf nur vorausschicken
aufgrund der guten kooperation im jagd
kommando und kommt dann ist das war ich
ja komme ich bei all diesen einsätzen
schon einmal dabei und habe gesehen dass
die soldaten vor ort wirklich diese
unterstützung brauchen und können
letztlich nur eine konkrete frage und
eine verteidigungsschrift doktor
schweiger ein potenzial gefragt gibt es
der gäbe ist ein beispiel wo dieser
folder oder ihre arbeit einen soldaten
die soldaten im einsatzgebiet geschützt
vielleicht sogar vor dem tod bewahrt
wir haben es den kollegen vom jagd
kommando mitgegeben über wir haben doch
kein feedback erhalten also wird man
darf ja auch nie was über die einsätze
sagen zum beispiel das ist ja immer so
eine sache aber ist sie haben gesagt das
ist gut anwendbar man kann es eigentlich
ganz gut bestimmen
wir haben sie mich selbst ausprobiert
ich muss sagen ich habe es einfach in
meiner ganzen familie getestet die
mussten alle irgendwelche tiere
bestimmen mit dem folder und schauen ob
das funktioniert weil für uns ist das ja
tägliches geschäft die arten zu kennen
und der folder funktioniert gut also es
ist sie können es gerne mal selber
ausprobieren jagdkommandos mitfahren
dann nehmen es den fall damit sie haben
ihren gekriegt und dann schauen sie sich
das an ob das funktioniert ich bedanke
mich für die frage und darauf
abschließend noch fragen seit wann die
fulda im einsatz sind 217 glaube ich
zwei 18 und man muss auch sagen hat man
das ist ganz eigentlich toll
die deutsche bundeswehr hat auch ein
großes kontingent für ihre
auslandseinsätze gekauft angekauft und
sie fragen jetzt mit unseren feldern in
die auslandseinsätze und das ist
eigentlich auch ganz fein meine damen
und herren hier vor ort und die online
zu sehr ich darf mich recht herzlich für
ihre für interesse bedanken und möchte
hiermit die pressekonferenz beenden
dankeschön